[Music]
at the moment it does seem like the odds
are stacked against the pm but um i will
never rule out a last minute surprise
i think it has less to do
with uh the way he's governed and it's
more to do with um
sort of whose stores he stepped on the
crisis as it was seems to have emerged
when uh imran khan
wanted to retain the current the
incumbent uh dgi said then government
isi
um who was said to be favorable towards
the government right and that created a
bit of a flap
with the military brass
the opposition has been trying to dcp
prime minister well ever since he became
the prime minister
um they are pointing towards um what
they call misgovernance they're talking
about uh crucial decisions that were not
taken in time they are of course talking
about what they call economic
mismanagement in which you can include
inflation
[Music]
and it is entirely likely that the
supreme court will rule against that say
that no that's that's uh you know overly
punitive right but the process does take
time
but i think we're heading towards uh
elections in in pakistan um and i think
that might end up happening regardless
of how the motor propulsion
goes down
[Music]